[Music]
hey you guys tomes of terror time it's
horror book review time
and uh this time around we're going more
horror than we
have been the last few weeks because i
feel like the last one was kind of a
whodunit and
we've been doing more psychological
horror but this
right here is more of a horror horror
and this is kin by kalyn patrick burke
now this is a book that i have seen uh
recommended
in many places on goodreads on various
other book review channels that i've
read so i was like really excited to
read it
caleb patrick burke i guess is an irish
writer this is the first book of his
that i've read
he did actually win a bram stoker award
for his novel the turtle boy which i
have not read yet
and um i've seen some of his other stuff
recommended as well i think he did a
novella called sour candy which a lot of
people talk about a novella called
blanky which a lot of people talk about
as well
so i'll probably get around to those
eventually
but i'm just saying that i don't really
have a basis of comparison if like you
know this is
similar to the style or the subject
matter of his other books
but um so i can just kind of judge it on
its own merits
i will say i don't usually do this like
for the reviews like especially
considering the
the books that i've reviewed thus far um
this one
is gonna have a content warning now if
you do not like
um horror stories about excessive gore
rape cannibalism uh you know limbs being
cut off of vicious eviscerations people
being sown inside of other people
stuff like that um if you don't like
that this is probably not the book for
you this is
very very gory very extreme very over
the top
but that said it's also um a really good
book i found it a really compelling
uh story and there was some pretty gross
[ __ ] in it and it takes quite a lot to
gross me out but
some scenes in this kind of did this is
gonna be
more a lot of people have compared this
to texas chainsaw massacre
um deliverance hostile that kind of
stuff where it's like people that
kind of fall into the clutches of these
cannibalistic
backwoods rednecks and you know [ __ ]
ensues
but the thing that's kind of different
about this one that i don't think i've
ever
read another book that's kind of like
this or approached from this angle
is that it's not describing like a group
of people who
fall into the hands of these like crazy
like
hillbilly [ __ ] and then like
the [ __ ] that happens to them
this story actually begins after all of
that has happened
and one girl has escaped and
so the book kind of details the
aftermath like what happens in the
aftermath of it like people going back
to seek revenge
like you know just that kind of thing so
i thought that was like a really
fascinating
you know way to start a story and like
really kind of original because you
don't really see
a lot of you know these types of stories
told from that perspective so i thought
that was
actually uh pretty cool and like a
pretty cool idea so our main character
is a girl named claire lambert and
apparently you don't really know at the
very beginning of the book because they
don't give a lot of insight into her
character and stuff because basically at
the very beginning of the book she's
just
escaped from the clutches of this crazy
family
and you know is trying to get away and
she's been grievously wounded um she's
been raped multiple times you know she
has
a bunch of stab wounds uh she's had one
of her eyes cut out she's having her
fingers cut off some of her toes cut off
so she's uh
not in good shape but she is just trying
to get the hell away from this
place and she gets picked up
by a man named jack and his
son uh named pete who i guess
is about the same age as her so i guess
like 1920 somewhere around that area so
this all takes place in a place called
elkwood
alabama now as the story goes on you
actually
find out that claire her boyfriend danny
and two of their friends like another
couple had been
kind of doing a road trip or something
of that nature and had kind of just
at random decided to go wander around
this you know random
dinky little rural town and alabama and
had um
fallen afoul of a family of cannibals
kind of like the sawyer family but
much much worse if i could say that
these are the merrell
clan now the merrell's are
uh it's you know it's an older man named
papa in gray
and uh his wife mama in bed
who is basically like this big enormous
like fat woman um who can't get out of
bed and she's just
been in the bed a long time and like all
of their sons
uh they did once have a daughter but
they get into what happened to her at
some point
these people they're these kind of
really really
backwoods rural and you know and they're
also like really like
religious nuts you know what i mean like
they actually really think
that god has told them
that they have to kill what they call
the men of the world
so they actually believe that they are
doing the right thing by just killing
people
that wander into their land and
also torturing them raping them eating
them
stealing all their stuff like basically
doing that and they don't really seem to
think
i don't know if i'd say that they don't
seem to think there's anything wrong
with it but
they think that they're kind of on a
mission you know what i mean
so apparently the dad and the mom have
instilled this in their children uh the
youngest
child i wasn't real clear because they
have like a bunch of kids
i think the youngest kid is isaac and i
think he's 12
but they've basically all been trained
to be
killers so they're all essentially the
same as their parents
and uh they'll they will do whatever
their dad tells them to do because
for them like the word of their mom and
dad is like you know god's word
so they just go ahead and do whatever
with the raping and the killing now as i
said at the beginning of the book
you know these four college students who
are from you know somewhere
up north uh have been like kind of
vacationing down there and
you know wandered into these people's
territory
three of them including claire's
boyfriend have been killed in various
horrible ways i believe danny had his
face taken off like there was somebody
this is a terrible
like a lot of terrible [ __ ] happens in
this book okay so i'm just like warning
you
so claire as [ __ ] up as she is managed
to kill
one of the sons matt uh
who was a little bit slow and uh has
managed to escape and as i said she got
picked up
she got taken to a doctor who got her
scene to although her
injuries were kind of too he's kind of
like a country doctor you know his name
was doc wellman
and uh so he tried to help her out as
best he can but the boy
pete uh who was the son of jack who had
helped her out like found her in the
street like naked and bleeding and like
picks her up and took her the doctor
the doctor says you know to pete you you
know you guys will have to take her to
the bigger
hospital like you know the state
hospital or whatever because you know i
don't have the resources here this is
just my house you know she is
essentially the final girl this is
almost kind of like
if the texas chainsaw massacre you know
like the end where sally gets in the
truck
and then drives away like all bloody and
she's like laughing her ass off and then
you know leatherface is like god damn it
with the chainsaw and everything
this is essentially like what happens
after that
you know what i mean because she escapes
and then
uh one of the sons of the meryl family
luke who i think is the oldest
he is actually one of the only kids of
this
you know [ __ ] up family that is
actually starting to doubt that
what they're doing is the right thing um
so he's very conflicted about it
so he is given the task to kind of like
you know save face because uh you know
there was some stuff with his sister you
know who the family murdered and
you know i won't get too much into that
because that's kind of like a side plot
but that was one of the things that has
started to turn him against his family
and has um
you know showed him that maybe what
they're doing is wrong
so he's having doubts about that but he
so to kind of get back in his dad's good
graces
uh papa and gray sends him to go fetch
the girl like get her back
so they can like kill her like they
killed the rest of her friends and eat
her
like to take her strength or whatever he
actually fails in that because
she gets rescued before he can get to
her at which point
the merrell clan decide that they're
going to have to
since they couldn't find her they decide
they're going to punish the people
that that helped her get away and
they're also going to have to
move somewhere else and at some point
they figure
and rightly so that some people are
going to come back
looking for them so basically what the
point of this story is i mean it's
called
kin and they're talking about you know
kin
the merrell family obviously the crazy
lunatic like
bible thumping cannibals who live out in
the woods and kill people for
shits and giggles um they're talking
about that
but they're also talking about the kin
of the victims like the people
it's kind of almost like this one
tragedy that happened like you know
these three people that got killed this
one
woman that almost got killed when she
was like you know [ __ ] she's like
[ __ ] up and messed up like beyond
you know recognition like her whole
entire life has changed
um so it's almost kind of like all the
tendrils that sprout
forth from that because what happens
after that
is that uh the brother of one of uh
claire's boyfriend who was uh murdered
down there
he decides he wants to go back and take
this family out claire decides she wants
to go back
pete has kind of fallen in love with her
and he wants to go back and punish them
because what ends up happening is that
the merrell family
are one so mean and horrible and will
basically
kill anyone that [ __ ] with them but
also they own
a whole bunch of the land like in the
county so
basically everybody kind of knows that
what they've been up to
like every time a stranger wanders into
the town and like is never seen again
everyone's just like
you know what i mean so everyone just
kind of pretends that it's not happening
um you know including the authorities
and everything so basically
after she gets away there's kind of like
a cover-up
in this little town because nobody wants
the merrell clan coming after them
so it's almost kind of like some people
have to decide if they want to
risk their own life you know to do the
right thing and bring these people to
justice or take them out or whatever
so it's basically kind of like there's
all these different characters
you know who weren't there uh you know
they didn't see what happened to her
but are affected by it all the same
either because
one of their relatives was killed there
or because
you know there's a thing with pete and
like his stepmom um you know and him
kind of going off and finding her and
like her kind of getting involved
even though she you know was in a
completely different city and everything
that's kind of what it's so it's kind of
like the aftermath of the tragedy and
it's almost
i don't know if i'd say that it's
hammering a point home of
you know one atrocity causing a bunch of
other ones or like me
or turning people into monsters
akin to what the merrell clan were
because i don't think
anyone's gonna come away from it
thinking that those
people didn't deserve to be like taken
out because
they absolutely did like all the [ __ ]
that they did but it's interesting how
you know one of the characters named
finch uh
his brother was killed uh by
the family and he you know he's kind of
an iraqi war veteran and he kind of like
you know was there i don't know if it
was like abu ghraib or whatever but he's
kind of like oh it's like
it is kind of like having his own uh
ptsd about [ __ ] he did over there
and like you know killing innocent
people and so it's almost kind of like
he knows what's gonna happen when he
goes there and he knows it's not really
the right thing to do he's giving into
his anger he's doing this and the other
thing but it's almost like he can't stop
himself
um so it's kind of that too it's kind of
like talking about how some people
just need revenge or need you know need
that kind of closure even though they
know
even if they know like they don't
necessarily think it's going to bring
them any closure it's almost like they
have to do it
so it kind of has a lot of that too like
i will say now i've seen
some some reviews most of the reviews of
this are very good some reviews seem to
say like the beginning of it's really
good and the end of it's really good but
some of the middle part was
like sagged a little which i don't think
i necessarily agree with that it's not a
really long book
the type is actually really small
um so it's actually like longer than it
appears i guess because i think the page
count is almost like 200 or something
but um you know the
like i said the the font is a little bit
smaller so it's
actually kind of longer than like more
[ __ ] happens in it but i will say that
you know the beginning which is really
compelling about her escaping
and you know the father and son picking
her up and then like them
realizing that now there's a target on
their back because you know they helped
her
and then like the kind of cover-up and
you know the anger that that
stirs up in the characters as well as in
the reader but then after that it kind
of goes
for a second i was kind of like i was
reading it and i'm like well wait
who's this now you know what i mean so
it's kind of like there's a lot of
characters
that were only like tangentially related
to like the original incident
it takes a little bit of time to kind of
get into
because it goes back and forth a lot
like to um
you know to this character to that
characters it goes from pete and like
looking for his mom and then it goes
like back to finch and him
trying to figure out where this family
has gone so he can go get them and then
it's talking about claire and it's
talking about you know her relationship
with her sister and
all this other kind of stuff so there's
a there's a lot of characters and it
switches back and forth between them
like pretty uh freely
so know that going in like that's kind
of the middle part
is everyone kind of figuring out what
they're gonna do how they're gonna like
come to the
you know conclusion of this you know or
put this behind them and
you know their own ways of dealing with
the grief and the trauma and things like
that so
there so there's a lot of that and so it
might seem like when you first read it
and you're like this it has this world
bang like
really graphic gory beginning and then
it kind of just goes into like
the mode where it's just back and forth
all the characters and they're just like
figuring out what they're gonna do like
they're planning and stuff
but like i said that didn't bother me
but i have seen i mean i can see why
some people were bothered by that but i
wasn't bothered by that now again
i will say that if you are not a fan of
i wouldn't call this torture porn but if
you're not a fan of that kind of thing
you will probably not like this because
it is very graphic
it is very gory a lot of people die a
lot of really [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens
so just be warned if that doesn't sound
like something you would like like i
said the gore didn't bother me all that
much
some things that bothered me were more
like because some of the descriptions of
like
mama in bed's room and like like how it
smelled and stuff
that probably made me sicker than like a
lot of the gore which i don't know what
that says about me
in a way that's like that's a compliment
to like keelan patrick burke's writing
though because
the fact that he actually like made me
smell it you know what i mean it's like
because the writing is like very very
descriptive
uh which is one reason i think that the
gore hits so much harder
because he's so good at like describing
what it looks like describing what it
smells like
um you know so it almost kind of like
puts you in it it's like very it's like
an abattoir you know what i mean
another thing i really liked was that he
kind of goes a lot
into the merrell family and like their
the family are monsters essentially
they're just horrible horrible people
who should just wipe be wiped off the
face of the earth
but i like that he kind of i don't know
if i'd say he humanizes them but he does
like
have some chapters where he says what
you know what their thoughts are at
least what papa and gray's thoughts are
and like i said the the son luke that is
uh starting to question
uh the authority of his dad and like
maybe what they're doing is
wrong so there's some of that and i like
that because that's
that gave it like another dimension and
uh the family itself were actually
as horrible as they were they were
actually kind of interesting
just because you know even though
they're clearly villains
they're doing it for a purpose like they
think they have a purpose
and they think that it's divinely
ordained which is messed up which is
it's even more messed up than somebody
just doing it
for re just because randomly or like for
fun or because they get off on it or
something
they actually have like a whole twisted
world view
that makes them scarier in my opinion
and i so i like those scenes where
he kind of goes into their heads or like
goes into
like what their whole what their whole
entire world view is and it's like
really really messed up
i don't know i don't know if i'd say
it's like two sides of the same coin
because you know they're
hunting people you know that come onto
their land and they think they have a
right to
and then you have all these people on
the other side the good people
who are also essentially gonna go and
hunt them just as punishment for what
they did to this girl
like i said i don't think he's making a
statement it's like oh these people are
no better than those people because
that's obviously [ __ ]
it's it's just an interesting story the
way it's kind of like
you know violence begetting violence and
the just this one
you know atrocity inspiring a bunch of
other ones in a bunch of people who
weren't
even there so i think that was like kind
of a cool aspect of the story that i
really liked
it made it a lot more thought provoking
than just
a gore fest or just like a regular kind
of slasher
texas chainsaw massacre kind of thing it
actually had something to say and it had
like a lot of depth to it so i really
liked that a lot but yeah as i said i
really really liked this book i found it
very
compelling uh very well written very
descriptive like the
you know the description of some of this
stuff was actually quite
beautiful even though it's a lot of the
imagery is very grotesque
but as i said if you don't like really
gross [ __ ] like really gory [ __ ]
then this will not be your cup of tea
but if you do like really kind of more
extreme horror if you like like jack
ketchum
or um richard layman maybe if you like
authors like that then you will probably
dig this as well
i believe um and i haven't read it yet
because i reviewed another anya
alborn book i reviewed uh if you see if
you see her like a few weeks ago
but apparently she also wrote a book
called brother
which i've heard is very similar to this
one although not quite as graphic
um so i'll probably get to that one as
well like eventually
and i'll see if it's as similar as a lot
of people have said but a lot of people
brought that
up if you're really into like extreme
horror really graphic horror
then you will probably dig this a lot
and uh like i said i'll
be reading some of his other books too
in the future and we'll review some of
those too so that'll do it for this
tomes of terror and i'll see you on the
next one bye